[Music]
I needed to lose you to love me
Selena Gomez released her new song lose
you to love me and it's just as personal
and perfect as you'd expect
[Music]
I need
me
[Music]
of course fans on Twitter couldn't help
but notice all the references that are
seemingly about Justin Bieber and they
aren't wrong he or she things quote in
two months you replaced us like it was
easy it was easy if you'll remember
selena and Justin were hanging out a lot
just before Halley and Justin reunited
and then there's this part Selina
mentioning purpose which is also the
name of Bieber's last album Bruce Kulick
lose his office toured said fired him on
purpose and I let it burn my whole thing
was to tell people that whether you feel
like you don't have a purpose so you
feel like you want to find your purpose
purpose is such an important thing in
life and I just wanted to use my
platform to tell people that I guess and
remember how Jelena used to share these
videos of them dancing well she sings
this
[Music]
all I know is I am so here for all this
selena realness and honesty it's amazing
and how's this for a fun fact about the
video it was shot entirely on the iPhone
11 Pro I needed to lose you to love me
earlier this year Selena opened up about
how nervous she was for fans to hear her
new music on an Instagram live right now
it's going really go I'm just nervous
about it honestly because I feel like
the next few choices that I'm gonna make
are very crucial so I'm trying to be
really really diligent and just patient
with everything shortly after that a
source told ET Selena would be releasing
new and very personal new music by
year's end I love you guys so much and I
was coming very soon and everything's
good
I'm super super happy Selena's friends
are also loving the new tune Taylor
Swift posted this no word on how J Lee
feels yet though fans are really reading
into this song hailey posted about on
her insta just minutes after Selena's
new song came out hailey has since
responded to all that speculation though
saying quote please stop with this
nonsense there is no response this is
complete BS alright guys what do you
think of Selena's new song and video I
love it
let me know though and for all the
latest on Selena keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
crafts and bye for now
[Music]